are you like this like if you see a bad
crowd hey I know I understand I put the
nerd and the football guy I know but I
was perceived you have the shirt on dude
it's like um I'm going to tell you about
him okay in the late 90s early 2000s
there was a place called Dublin's that
we would do stand-up on that's what I
meant to do there's his box that he has
in his room a chest of photographs and
3/4 of them are of Dublin's yeah and I
got there are a lot of pictures of you
there that's know you've always had them
this is when um you still had you know
you have to develop the photos Oh
are you sure that was what the normal
New Orleans photos with Vince Vaughn I
have those too I remember that yeah he's
a great gig you know that was fun yeah
that was fun weekend but um and then
it's redundant at Dublin's
Bob winter Dublin's Dublin's jzjz Ahmed
Ahmed yeah Davis why do you pause when I
said I'm in about because I was not your
uncle
I was not connecting I met I met with
jay-z for a minute I was like did they
collab oh gee I think Jay Davis running
no jay-z jay-z the boy all right that's
my jay-z I hate myself right now but
jay-z did what mm mm there and then uh
and then but all minimun and Jay Davis
ran the room just run Tuesdays yeah and
it was a free show upstairs in an Irish
pub Murray yeah and um I have to say
free show Frank yep and I have to say it
was just one of those nights where and
I've never seen anything like it I don't
think since it was always packed it was
always it felt like this is the place to
be
right like you wouldn't have been able
sorry sir looks like he looks like you
would have owned the place don't be nice
to him he never gets kindness from any
of us yeah yeah free show you said I
can't look just like shunned him
visually I've never shunned someone
visually before don't look at this
little [ __ ] guy right I love him
though but yeah I was free he would have
been looking in and it was like but and
I have to and if I'm blowing wind up
your bong bong bong you have to kind of
admit to some things though which is of
there which are realities situation oh I
often call you the truth detector so he
has a motto that's where he says I lied
to win yes not enough truth detector
Lila I lied but you know what that's the
truth thank you for the bass man I love
it but the whole show was revolved
pretty much around your sex I don't
think it was revolved but I did close
out a lot of those shows down there oh
the man thing was happening I felt it I
literally felt like after all the years
of being like okay I can get some lat
I felt the consistency yeah in week to
week as I was performing there I'm being
serious like I knew over that first year
I was there I was like oh I'm becoming
something yeah and you could feel it
because you know you'd go to the comedy
store back then was terrible and there's
just no one in the audience even on a
weekend and you and it's it was almost
as if like this style of performance is
something of the past it felt like like
this it's dead but then you go to the
Dublin's and you go no it's young it's
super hip can we get him some coffe
suppresser that's the way he does it
what happened
I had the same exact Cossack for her yes
now are we gonna round-robin this what's
gonna happen are you getting a signal
it's post nasal drip it's making your
throat adji I have the same thing okay
you're gonna be fine the pressure you
just lay on your back and keep Rico lies
in your mouth yeah anyway it was like
young like you know I remember going
there and like yeah they're all this
pretty Spears yeah yeah although them
would come out like all the cool yes
back then and we were cool kids with the
cool kids
I didn't feel that but yeah well you
were 47 years yeah we were the cool in
that environment that would seem like it
was our sweet spot and then it was um
you would go up and usually you would
have a good set and then afterwards it
would be like um like I was the only
time this has ever happened where every
time you'd had somebody giving you a car
like a business car right like I'm from
this huge company I'm Dave Becky I'm
this you know yeah yeah and they would
want to you know do what business with
you was that incredible but the whole
thing was surrounded revolved around him
right and he would come out and that was
like you know I mean I had seen people
crush before I've seen back in the late
90s I saw Pablo Francisco rip up a room
once you know I've seen Mencia although
you know we know about him but he we
know I've seen Mencia in a packed room
you know the in San Antonio rip up a
room right it's I've seen it you know
and I've seen you rip up I'm done okay
and then I've seen him you know the
captain doesn't get um compliments and
but it was something there was a weird
thing happening where people were like
that's that that guy like you know that
you yeah after that you're God it was it
was unbelievable man it literally was I
remember the first two times doing the
gig versus you know maybe like a year
and a half later I was getting paid like
you know whatever some some pretty
decent college gigs and then a year and
a half later I was like living my dream
my pipe dream of what I hoped
would be yeah happened while I was
incubating at Dublin's
[Music]